let's come forward from 1913 to the
Depression era and the role that the Fed
played in that the inflation deflation
cycle would you like to comment on that
yes a lot of people you can still find
in history books that the economists
were reassured in the 1920s that there
was no inflation prices were relatively
stable and they always said that
inflation was rising prices but if you
look at the monetary history there was a
lot of monetary inflation during the
1920s and the money instead of going
into production
it went into speculation of course it
bit up the price of stocks and real
estate and then it finally came to that
time when there is concern or are they
make the decision look I think we think
we can not only save the DAR and stop
the inflation but we can make some money
on it and they say we're going to have
to turn this off so they cut back on the
credit and it caused the stock market
crash and of course then a Great
Depression followed the inflation always
leads to a correction of the need of a
recession or depression but if you
compare what happened in the 1920s very
similar what's happening here in the
1980s and you just think about how many
times you read in the last six or eight
years that the government's told us
there's nothing to worry about there's
no inflation well there's been a greater
expansion of money now than it was in
the 20s of course there was a greater
speculation in stock market and a bigger
stock market crash so I anticipate and
many Austrians free-market economists
anticipate that the recession that's
coming will not be a recession at all to
be a depression probably bigger than
when we have the 1930s because it will
be the correction for all the
malinvestment all the mistakes made
because of this artificial credit pumped
in by the Federal Reserve System so we
have to look for the correction the next
president will be blamed for the
depression but it is that they shouldn't
get the blame it should be the full
reserve policy in the regular
ministration and the Congress today who
have run up the debts and created the
new money that has set the stage for the
next recession the next recession or
slant and depression if it becomes that
do you have an idea in mind for when
that might begin we see all these books
out now the Great Depression of 1990 and
I have an idea but the most important
thing about Austrian economics is that
you cannot project precisely because
events occur with emotional aspects
human beings making decisions that's why
although many including myself kept
saying there's going to be a stock
market right but I didn't know it was
going to be October 19 they could have
been October 10th or could have been
November 15th I mean it comes when
people just get frightened and scared
and panic so Austrian economics teaches
that yes we know a depression is coming
but we don't know the day it's going to
start but still a lot of people say well
what do you think because you just have
to make a judgment for personal and
financial reasons I think it's going to
there's going to be another major
financial event before the end of this
year close to the election more likely
before than afterwards and that by next
year next spring
it'll be very clear that this country is
moving rapidly into a recession we put
that question to congressman Gonzalez
your former colleague on the housing
banking currency committee and I said
well I've been reading a lot about how
the next presidents gonna be the next
Herbert Hoover and he said if we're
lucky the depression won't wait that
long and I wouldn't argue a whole lot
but but time is running short here we
are in August already and a recession
could start tomorrow or the next day it
could be very clear I think matter of
fact the standard of living has been
going down I think history is going to
show that the country has been down on
the down slope maybe for the past ten
years it's just not going rapidly and
it's not confirmed by the government
statistics but they're changing all the
time they use GNP figures to reassure us
everything is OK and 40 percent of GNP
is government spending and where do they
get the money they print it and also you
know like for CPI they change in that if
it's going up too fast things the way
they calculate it if you go to the
average guy on the street and say is
your cost of living going on because I
can't even pay my bills I'm not even
buying the steak anymore and so things
are a lot worse than the government
leads to believe can we get back to this
matter
political power you can economic power
and control of the economy were you in
Congress when Wright Patman was still
there no but I was in Congress when his
son was there okay I think it's bill
Patman that was there but I didn't know
Wright Patman Wright Patman of course
was the chairman of the Banking
Committee one time and he had some good
ideas about the Federal Reserve oh he
had in my Studies on the American power
structure it was a real gold mine
because his Committee on which you came
on later made studies of how the big
banks the United States control the
corporations in the United States and
it's incredible
through interlocking directorates in
stock ownership would they I guess did
you see much of this when we were there
I mean not in the detail that he had
looked at it but it's obviously very
clear the one thing that I picked up
from Wright Patman was his bill to audit
the Federal Reserve and I've only made
minor modifications to I dug that out
and and he of course was a champion of
openness in government he wanted to know
what the Federal Reserve was doing and
he never finally I think in his older
years they had voted him out of that
power position you know even before he
was out of Congress he lost his position
they put in Henry's Royce who was much
more control by the banking people but
he he was a good person and he wanted
more openness I don't know if he was as
strong on the gold standard as I am but
he certainly was against the type of
banking system and how that how the
banking system the Federal Reserve serve
the interests of the bankers and large
corporations the bankers control the
mass media to literally control other
major industries in the United States
probably so certainly a lot of people
say that I guess I hesitate only that I
don't have you know the proof sitting in
my hand but I think it's very clear I
can see it in government and I saw it in
banking and certainly it can't be
surprising if they're involved with
other large corporations why the media
would be very much involved - it would
be more of a surprise to find that not
to be the case but I don't think I could
take him into court right now and give
them that proof that is necessary but I
think
those who have studied it feel that that
is the case